we found a thread and this thread
is nuts before we get to the thread we
are going to show you very quickly two
high-level
charts graphs uh visualizations whatever
you want to call them the infrastructure
bill
breakdown here's the first one uh 1.2
trillion dollars
we know that there's various parts of it
etc
but 1.2 trillion is in total spending
over eight years
we got it roads and bridges power grid
freight rail broadband water resilience
airports that's what you're told is in
this infrastructure bill all right just
so we're all clear here
roads and bridges power grid freight
rail broadband water resilience
airports okay next here's the comparison
between the original proposal
and the bipartisan plan that ended up
being approved so at first it was 2.6
billion dollars
is where we uh were going to uh
start from the original proposal and
where we ended up was 550 billion about
20 or so of where we started now you can
see in-home care not in there building's
not in there innovation not in there and
i love how they just
label things innovation the government
is not very innovative i don't know
where they were gonna put money
to be innovative but uh innovation is
not now
a mandate of the us government based on
this bill now
what is in there is there's some
transportation pollution utilities all
that sounds amazing like we should be
really excited
about being able to look at utilities
transportation roads and bridges power
grid etc
i think most people would say this is
the type of stuff that i
believe that the government could
provide if done correctly
but there is a person on twitter of
course
who appears to have gone through the
bill and i don't think they went through
the entire bill it's thousands of pages
uh literally saw the pictures 2700 pages
there was a picture of the pages all
printed out like this i have no clue who
writes this stuff
whoever sits there and actually writes
out the entire bill is a
psychopath there's zero chance that you
could pay me to sit there
and write 2 700 pages of government
worded
documents that they continue to change
over and over again like what are they
like hey go to page 700
1742 and on line six can you change the
comma to a period section 46 subsection
a
that's literally what happens on this
stuff so our friend
uh was his oilfield rando which by the
way is an amazing
twitter name oilfield rando went through
and i don't even know where to start
with this but he started out
i'm going to use he cause i don't know
if it's a he or she but he started out
and said already found 250 million
dollars for an invasive
plant species removal program
lol infrastructure
now when i first there's the first tweet
that i saw in this and i was like this
can't possibly be that ridiculous so i
click
through on the uh one side there on that
very first tweet i clicked through
and this is what it says it says
invasive plant the term
invasive plant means a a non-native
plant
tree grass or weed species including at
a minimum
cheatgrass vatenta dubia
medusa head bulbous bull grass
japanese brome rattail fescue
japanese honeysuckle phagomy
fragmitis fragmitis
autumn olive bradford pear
wild parsnip sierra lespedusa
spotted knapweed garlic mustard and
palmer
amaranth i dare one of our politicians
to read that [ __ ] out loud
i dare them there's not one politician
we have that can read that paragraph and
get it right
and by the way it's 2700 pages they
didn't read any of this
there's not a politician that read the
whole thing but that
one paragraph there's not a politician
we have the average age is 60 something
years old
they can't read the paragraph i can't
read the paragraph what is this stuff
i don't know but what i do know is that
our government's gonna spend money
to go after the rat tail fescue
or the japanese honeysuckle
boobs and bridges or power grids or
utilities to me that sounds like we're
doing a science experiment
in nature that's what this sounds like
the program means the grant program
established under subsection grant
meaning we're gonna give away the money
for free
then if you continue in this thing you
see that
in the case of a project that utilizes
re-vegetation
with native plants and wildflowers
including those that are pollinator
friendly
75 percent and in the ease of any other
project
not described in subparagraph a 50
percent
certain funds counted towards
non-federal share a state may include
amounts expended by the state or a unit
of local government in the state to
address
current invasive plant populations and
prevent future
infestation along or in areas adjacent
to transportation
corridor rights of way in calculating
the non-federal share required under the
program
there is not one politician in this
country that can tell you what that
means
there's not one politician that can tell
you what the hell that is
i am a half-educated half-intelligent
half-moron and i read and i can't tell
you a single thing that this thing is
saying
this is insanity 250 million dollars
of the government spending is gonna go
to
invasive plant species removal program
what the hell does that mean i read it
and i still don't know
they didn't read it and they don't know
sound crazy well we're not done yet
the next thing is 50 million dollars
for studies on how to tax us more with
road usage and per mile fees
now again i click through because that
seems pretty ridiculous
strategic innovation for revenue
collection is literally the title of
this
they're gonna spend your taxpayer money
to figure out how to take more money
from you
that's how insane this is strategic
innovation for revenue collection
there's nothing strategic about this and
there is nothing innovative about this
all this is is they're gonna try to
figure out how to get more of your tax
money
and it says the secretary shall
establish a program to test the
feasibility of a road usage fee
and other user-based alternative revenue
mechanisms
to help maintain the long-term solvency
of the highway trust fund
through pilot projects at the state
local and regional level the secretary
shall provide grants to eligible
entities to carry out pilot projects
under this section
to be eligible for a grant under this
section an eligible entity shall submit
to the secretary an application at such
time
in such manner and counting such
information as the secretary may require
they took six lines to tell you to do
what the secretary said
that's how ridiculous this stuff is this
part of the bill
50 million dollars for studies if you
give me 50 million dollars i promise you
i'll show you how to get more
tax money it's simple just write a law
that's it they don't need 50 million
dollars to study
how to take more tax money from you we
don't have a revenue problem in this
country we got a spending problem this
isn't a damn example
50 million dollars in this bill again
the bill's 550
billion dollars so 50 million just gets
snuck in here here here so now we are
solving invasive plant species in our
country
and we also are going to do studies in
order to figure out how to get why do
you need 50 million dollars for this
a toll's pretty simple to me right like
how many how many cars pass through
how much does it cost to build a
facility and hire the workers and pay
their wages and all this kind of stuff
yeah what are we going to charge and how
much are we going to collect it seems
like a simple job
in a week itself well i i was going to
actually offer at the end of this
we don't need 550 billion dollars to do
something if you just pay us a million
the the best business show we got you
we'll do the math yeah a million you
keep the rest give us a minute
we'll study the roads we'll study the
tolls we'll literally
write down with a pencil if everyone
knows how this goes if the government's
writing the check give us 50 and then
we'll use one to do it
well we might outsource it sources yeah
that's exactly what's going on i'd
outsource them
next one is a study on people hitting
deer
[Music]
we gotta we gotta say this guy's a
little now again
i i click through i wanna read i i see
the headline
study on people hitting beer section
wildlife vehicle collision research
pretty damn accurate if you read this
a representative from a state local
regional wildlife land use or resource
management agency
they go through this whole thing right
and you start to understand
that literally it is a study on people
hitting animals
what does that have to do with
infrastructure what we were told was
roads
bridges power grids utilities etc
this was not what we were told is in
this build
continue on 50 million dollars for 10
transportation resilience and adaptation
centers of excellence which will do
climate change reports and engage
disadvantaged communities
now again if i click through to it i
don't know anything about this
but that doesn't sound like what they
told us was actually in the bill
so if we continue this is my favorite
one this is all time
i actually want matt to pull this one up
but don't pull up the tweet can you pull
up like hide the uh tweet before you
pull it up
and just click through on the actual uh
um
image if possible maybe it's not
possible all right i'll just actually go
to the tweet screw it
update upgraded amtrak train service in
canada
the us government is spending money on
the amtrak
stations in canada that is what is in
the bill
again let's click through there's no way
that that is possible click through
enhancing cross-border
service seems like it could be
infrastructure related
not later than one year after the date
of enactment of this act amtrak
after consultation with the secretary
the secretary of homeland security
relevant state departments of
transportation canadian governmental
agencies and entities and owners of the
relevant rail infrastructure and
facilities shall submit a report to the
committee on commerce science and
transportation of the senate and the
committee on transportation and
infrastructure
of the house of representatives
regarding enhancing amtrak passenger
rail service between the united states
and canada
identifying the challenges to amtrak
operations in canada
including delays associated with customs
and immigration inspections in both the
united states and canada
includes recommendations to improve such
cross-border service including the
feasibility of
costs associated with a i don't even
know what that word is facility
or facilities they literally want to
study
why the amtrak is getting stopped at
customs
this is insanity but this is what's in
the bill
nobody ever looks and so we can keep
going through this there's things like
combating human trafficking
uh there's things like promoting more
lady truckers uh or or i guess women
truckers
jesus christ this guy's tweets are
unreal uh there's uh studying the safety
of limousines
there is uh new cars having to be
equipped with uh breathalyzers i think
is one of them
so advanced drunk and impaired driving
prevention technology safety standard
subject to the subsection and not later
than three years after the date of
enactment of this act
the secretary shall issue a final rule
prescribing a federal motor vehicle
safety standard
under this section that requires
passenger motor vehicles manufactured
after the effective date of that
standard to be equipped with advanced
drunk and impaired driving prevention
technology
now again i'm not a genius half genius
half [ __ ] but if we want breathalyzers
in the car
tell them to put breathalyzers if we
don't want breathalyzers in the car
tell them not to put breathalyzers why
do we need a
study to know what the impact of that
will be
my guess is that there will be less
drunk drivers if
they have breathalyzers in the car
that's another math problem i could do
probably for a fee
i don't know but we got you i promise
you we don't need 50 million dollars
guess what if we want to cut down on
drunk driving put breathalyzers in the
car
if you don't want to cut down on drunk
driving don't put breathalyzers in the
car
it's not that difficult we are literally
watching a 2700 page document that's
gonna spend 550 billion dollars that
your politicians didn't read
and they couldn't tell you what half the
stuff in here is and even after you read
it
you don't know what it is because you
can't pronounce half of it so if you
just continue
there's literally a study on smoking
weed and driving
can't can't make it up report on
marijuana research
i love how this this guy or girl uses
like five words to describe
smoking weed and driving infrastructure
report on marijuana research the
definition of marijuana
that's the start of the other thing
definition of marijuana in this section
the term marijuana has the meaning given
the term in
the section whatever by the way if they
use the word marijuana they're cops
everyone knows that on the internet
report not later than two years after
the date of enactment on this act the
secretary in consultation with the
attorney general the secretary of health
and human services
shall submit to the committees on
commerce science and transportation
and judiciary of the senate and
committees on transportation and
infrastructure
and the judiciary of the house of
representatives and make publicly
available on the website
a report that describes methods for and
contains recommendations with respect to
increasing
and improving for scientific researchers
studying impairment while driving under
the influence of marijuana
access to samples and strains of
marijuana and products containing
marijuana that are lawfully available to
patients and consumers in a state or a
retail basis
is this saying that the government's
going to buy weed wait where do you get
that
increasing and improving for scientific
researchers studying impairment while
driving under the influence of marijuana
access to samples and strains of
marijuana
and products containing marijuana that
are lawfully available to patients or
consumers in a state or
retail basis so like we're going to buy
weed with this money we're going to give
it to some of our employees and we're
going to tell them
we're going to test them to drive
does that say the government is going to
buy weed for research purposes or not
i don't know i just read it i don't know
that's a government job
i think i know some people that might be
admitted
this is i'm literally reading the
document i'm not a complete [ __ ]
only half a [ __ ] and i don't know what
it says
does that what do you guys think does
that say the government is going to buy
samples of marijuana to study the
impairment
of driving while under the influence of
weed someone said in the comments i got
some buddies who probably have years of
knowledge driving high
the government can just consult them
bring the weed
i mean this is just nuts right so we
continue obviously there are some good
things in here right there's green
energy
subsidies and all this kind of i'm not
saying that's a good thing but i'm just
saying there are things that are
infrastructure related
but then when you start to get even
further down i'm going to skip a bunch
of these because
our oil-filled rando friend is
absolutely on
fire in some of these tweets uh there's
250 million dollars for electric ferries
uh then we get to the part where we're
selling 87 million barrels of oil from
the strategic petroleum reserve
that's in there and you got 2.6 billion
dollars uh
for the noaa and then there's a part
where it says 50 million dollars for
utah
and i had to read through this a couple
times because exactly what to say is 50
million
for utah there's mitt's payout and i was
like wait what does that mean and then i
was like oh mitt romney utah okay what
does that mean
so i went in and i read it even more the
central utah project completion account
wait there's an account and we're gonna
put 50 million in it for an additional
amount
for the central utah project completion
account 50 million dollars to remain
available until expended
of which 10 million shall be deposited
into the utah
reclamation mitigation and conservation
account for use by the utah reclamation
mitigation and conservative
conserva conservation commission
provided that such amount
is designated by the congress as being
for an emergency requirement pursuant
to this the concurrent resolution on the
budget for fiscal year 2018
and to this section this is how politics
works
50 million dollars why did why does the
central utah project completion account
get it
or why does the utah reclamation
mitigation and con conservation
commission get it
is nevada's conservation committee not
important what about texas or oklahoma
or new york or florida or georgia or
hawaii
maybe even puerto rico should get some i
don't know but what i know is that this
stuff's crazy
right and maybe they need the money
that's fine but the fact that citizens
are looking at and saying that's the
payout for a specific
person who worked on the bill pretty
crazy